we are never gonna write together if you
can't sum up we shouldn't wow-wow-wow
like a rainbow spectrum of ideas be
kidding with your intellect creativity
and my ability to make dick jokes we can
have something powerful hey guys I'm
Ryan right I'm Katy dubov we're gonna
check out the trailer today for mr.
house mr. Holmes Oh Watson you'll be
home tonight you look more like Benedict
Cumberbatch than I do thank you no
problem I'll leave you think I got a
Martin Freeman thing going on or a Jew
laughing you gotta kind of the rubber
down anything going on I'm gonna take
that as a compliment
and you also have any and McKellan thing
going on I do I like Ian McKellen a lot
you shall not ah yeah that was great
terrible you shout out boss boss
that's what I say whenever it Gandalf
hears someone fart mr. Holmes here we go
official teaser trailer appropriate
people
mr. Ames is it alright for Roger
phasers
I want more hey what's it about
what's he trying to solve his own
mystery of where the woman of his life
went so was love and stuff I think so
okay I think it was love I thought I was
about this woman I think there was a
picture there was a last kiss that
happened a long time ago
and there's a boy that's all I know but
I want to see it was he very saying he
was in love with a boy no I'm saying
that maybe the boy is his son maybe the
boy is connected somehow grandpa okay I
get the impression that he like loved
this woman and that John Watson got
jealous and killed the woman but
Sherlock has been looking for her body
for all these years because John was in
love with Sherlock I feel like maybe
you're you're making stuff up that
wasn't I'm just really good at
deciphering trailers one thing that
seems a little bit disappointing to me
is you know you hear Holmes
yes Sherlock Holmes like you kind of
want a cool detective story at the same
time right you know like the theory of
everything got really good feedback but
there but even the really good feedback
would say something along the lines of
let it's Steven Hawkings and Hawking
hockey right nuts hugging's I don't want
to get this wrong like an idiot
hockey Stephen Hawking like everyone was
saying like it's about Stephen Hawking
they could have explored his whole life
and the mysteries but they only focus on
this one love story and I kind of feel
that way about this like it could be a
great film still Ian McKellen could
still deliver one of his like greatest
performances for all I know like come on
it's true like home let's get like
[ __ ] detective [ __ ] going yeah you
know I wonder actually this trailer was
so brief and so sort of one-dimensional
I wonder if they're gonna release
another trailer I hope so I mean it's
from BBC Films and I think that's cool
that the actual British dudes are
involved yeah but it does feel like a
BBC I did feel like the music sort of
sounded down
yeah I wonder if it's the same composer
they're going for a different vibe than
what we're especially with the
modern-day ages scene of Sherlock Holmes
is becoming his own Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah
because there's two shows on television
the one where Lucy Liu plays Sherlock
Holmes or something have you seen that I
haven't seen it and then you got you
know Sherlock then you got the Sherlock
Holmes movies a Robert Downey jr. and
now you got this
yeah the bees so the bees bees are going
extinct are they no they are little
honey bees are what's the symbolism for
them here I don't know I mean there's
there's a lot of bee stuff in the
trailer maybe it's like Sherlock is at
the end of his time the bees are at the
end of his time their time his interest
with them maybe it has and he wants to
prick the woman one last time before he
dies he wants to just maybe you should
get a new body
he should get a new body and then we got
selfless yeah oh that would be great
like one selfless Sherlock selfless
selfless Holmes Holmes there we go
you guys well I've had to see in the
trailer for that movie don't understand
what we're talking about well guys
thanks for saying this trailer was out
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Katie du
Bois has a channel too you could check
it out I'm just gonna drop it she has a
idea that she's gonna be starting up
hopefully soon graphic novel reviews
that's right hot white girl reviewing
comic books you guys got your wish and
you can follow us on fit Facebook
Instagram Twitter and after that pics
pyx trying to get advertising here
pornhub.com youporn comm xvideos calm
that's right some people might be like
Ryan porn is not okay to all you liars
who watch the best jokes Katie - all you
liars who watch porn the camera cut and
I forgot the punch line whatever you
know it's one of those nights just gonna
throw my shoe how does the sandal
it's a shoe I threw it sandals not as
dramatic of an effect
it wasn't very dramatic here good
landing that's a perfect landing it was
yeah wow you can throw in a hangar
really well that's impressive thank you
thank you wow I should play like
baseball with you or something people
would be like you just gotta get mad
yeah oh yeah you'll like her when she's
minute just hit it out of the park hit
it at the park here why are things so
awkward when you become